can you get into property with zero
money even if you're just 19 20 years
old with absolutely zero experience and
the answer is yes you may remember about
12 months ago I interviewed A lady
called Charlotte and her partner Shai on
winners on a Wednesday and talked about
how I'd help them start from a scratch
and become financially free in just a
matter of months it's now 12 minutes
later how are they getting on well
they've got their own shop front right
here High living estate
they've got multiple members of staff
and are dominating it here in Birmingham
and they started with practically
nothing very young people with no
experience let's find out how they're
doing it how they've grown how much
money they're making and how you can do
the same thing too let's
[Music]
go this is
amazing wow I'm Ling the
logos and the gold and black so you'd
already got this place when you came on
winners most it was 3 months after we s
off so you came on winners winners
helped blow your business up then you
started hiring people and getting that's
so cool can you give me a little tour
tell me what's around and what course so
of course we have the the main office
where all the staff are yeah we have a
lovely Courtyard that we use with the
staff sometimes we do things like we
play giant jenger at here just for the
team you know for team building I think
it's really
important tell me then guys firstly how
did you get into proper how did you
start what was the kind of the beginning
beginning process I was working in
insurance and Sh was working in a law
firm um and when work would get quiet
I'd watch your videos told Charlotte
about them and was like this is what we
need to do so I just you know forget
this handing my notice um set the
business up yeah you guys quick you jump
like fast man like without even any
properties most definitely yeah so I've
handed him a notice and then told
Charlotte Charlotte was like yeah I'm
joining you let's do it um and then we
literally just left our jobs and then
just went fulltime into property and
just put everything we possibly could
yeah into making it happen why would
someone pay you to Source them a deal
when they can just find a deal
themselves like talk to talk to me
through that first deal like what was it
you said it was a HMO yeah so why would
they not just go to the agencies and
find a deal why would they come to you
we look on every single website we speak
to every single landlord we have
connections with and we get those
properties we do all the negotiations
we're pushing down on rent I think
that's the main thing a lot of people
don't have time it's the time it takes
and also a lot of investors if they're
going to book a day off work to go and
view properties and then negotiate for
maybe something to come of it maybe not
they'd rather just go you know what I'll
pay you three grand you go sort it out
how many deals on average are you
selling like a month say about 10 to
15 roughly yeah like the the last two
months for the business have been really
really good so max one of our staff
members he also works on sales now and
in one week he did five deals himself
which was amazing you must have targets
like what's your targets to be honest I
feel like the way we business is quite
relaxed um and I think instead of
applying additional stresses on
ourselves we kind of just see what we
can do because I feel like sometimes if
you set targets you can either limit
yourself or be a bit unrealistic if that
makes sense sure one of the downsides to
sourcing which a lot of people don't see
as a lot of deals do fall through so you
can sell say 15 deals but then maybe
only five of them will go through taking
that into account we try to get in as
much as possible in the case that deals
do fall through we've got enough that
can potentially compensate for that what
do you do when a deal falls through then
where does that leave you where does
that leave the investor so one big thing
for us is the relationship with the
investor for us that's probably the most
valuable thing so with that being said
we don't actually take the full £3,000
up front we take a deposit so we take a
deposit which is a little sum how much
rough like so about £500 and what that
basically does is secure the deal with
us and then takes off the market with us
and if it does fall through they will
get a full refund subject to terms and
conditions and this is where as well
when you're deal sourcing it's so
important to have clear terms and
conditions and everyone's running their
company very slightly differently you
know you found your kind of USP and you
found what works for you as a company
but it's so important to have clear
terms and conditions and also covering
but I know you guys are registered with
pims um talk to me what does what does
that mean exactly how does that work it
is that reassurance that if something
does go wrong and it is very unfortunate
they're covered there's someone who's
going to give them that solution there
there has the the trust I think when
people have the pins registration
definitely yeah and there's some form of
redress exactly you know you can't just
close down shop and that's it's another
interesting thing as well the fact that
you've got a like a shop or an office
whatever you want to call it do you find
that that builds trust with investors
well we did have one incident where a
client there wasn't comfortable with
paying the £500 deposit um and they were
very very very hesitant so we sent them
kind of all of the information the
website address and so on and then I was
at the printer and I seen them actually
drive P just as they drove pass they
sent us a message and said payment's
been sent and I think then just seeing
the office kind of built that instant
trust straight they can see you through
the window walking around yeah also as
well I'm guessing that there's been some
proper challenges because taking on
staff and I know you've got like a print
es and staff and you've got a you know
quite a lot of people within the team
now how how challenging has it been that
side of the business cuz I know I know
what that's like as a businessman is
hard we've had a lot of ups and downs
haven't we like even as the business you
know we got this office it's a big
overhead there a lot more overheads now
we have as a whole as we've grown I mean
there was months where staff were
getting paid and we weren't but we
pushed through and now we look at it and
like we've had the best month we ever
had in the business so it's pushing
through but it's so difficult when did
you turn over last
month I think it was around 30 it's just
under 30 about 30,000 and what kind of
profit margin have you got after you've
taken for your office and your staff and
everything uh you're looking at about 20
first then when you started out like
what was your now you've obviously got
like all this going on and you've
achieved loans talk me through that very
first deal what was the what was the
first project that you had first was a
HMO in cantry so we were kind of a
source in local to us of course based in
Birmingham it was in centry 5 bed HML
very luxurious High spare and then we
had the first set of training which was
the deal finding Extravaganza that was
in like a couple weeks time so I was
like let's get some deals ready for them
to sell them and then that's what we did
we we went to the train room sold the
deal there oh did you crazy yeah within
3 weeks we found our first deal and sold
it at the Tron would you have predicted
at that point this we had that drive
didn't we and one thing I said to you on
the winners on a Wednesday was I'd see
all these people on the winners
Wednesday and i' think well we can do
that these are just normal average
people and then when you see them and
then you meet them in real life as well
you really kind of see how their stories
are so genuine and you think we can do
it you have to believe it to be able to
achieve it and I always say to reach
certain level of success you have to
have a sense of delusion that makes
sense you have to believe that you can
get to a certain point to it's to the
point it's somewhat delusional and then
100% 100% and back it up with hard work
yeah also on the academy we talk a lot
about giving back and you've been
supporting uh a local charity yeah told
to me a little bit about that so we've
partnered with st basil charity as our
chosen charity of the year they
basically help rough sleepers aged
between 16 and 25 across the Midlands
and a big thing for us is we're making
so many people so much profit through
property but then there's a lot of
people that come from unfortunate
backgrounds where they're not even in a
fortunate position to even have a roof
over their head let alone be able to
invest in property so for us it's
if we're doing such a good deed in
helping people make money through
property we also need to help those that
don't even have a roof over their head
so we recently hosted a charity
networking event um and the funds raised
on that night was enough to provide I
think it was just over 70 nights of
housing for a lot of the kids that do
need housings what will be your top
pieces of advice then to someone
watching this video and they've got the
same fire you had maybe 2 3 years ago
where they man I want to be really
successful and I want to dominate in
property got much money not got much
experience what advice would you give to
them starting out I think the main thing
is that property is a people business
it's like how you always say like your
net worth really is your net worth like
it it makes such a difference the people
you have around you and another thing
that you always taught us that we kind
of n live by as well is never to be
greedy in property never it's like
always having the open hands approach
and I think that makes such a difference
to all the connections that you make
it's like you can do a good deed for
someone one month and then then you want
to hear from them 6 months and then they
come back and theyve remembered you for
that and I think in property that's
really big and that's why we focus on
the relationship most definitely and I
think another thing is don't give her it
is tough it's not easy but I think if
you allow those hard days to knock you
down you'll never get to what you aim it
for but if you continue pushing you'll
get the results 100% And I think that's
something a lot of people need to hold
on to so there you have it folks can you
start out with very little and build an
Empire while these guys have
demonstrated you absolutely can in
birming check them out High living
Estates also if you want to come meet me
and spend a day with me come and join us
at the one property investors crash
course there's no excuses I'll leave a
link in the description get booked on
I'll see you there peace
[Music]
out